Ciao Gu ciao ospite
Un giorno stavo facendo la spesa e ho assistito a un gioco che facevano padre e figlio
che è andato avanti per  tutto il supermercato e sono riuscita a fare un video...che ti allego
Grande!
e spiega la situazione
Grande! Guarda il video sei pronta?
Bellissimo questo gioco!... Ma è il mio video preferito!
Come si chiama"Maltratta tuo figlio" o "Chiama i servizi sociali"
Guarda che è felicissimo questo bambino. Questa qui è un alternativa ai vaccini
Cioè dopo che fai questa...Eh quando arrivi a casa hai qualsiasi malattia
Cioè se resisti a questa roba resisterai a qualsiasi altra
Ciao ragazzi ben tornati a una nuova puntata di "Vita Buttata"
Il tema della puntata di oggi è
"Che c***o ho appena visto
Per un tema così particolare ho
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia una persona per me
molto speciale, che di base è riuscita a
resistere ai conati che...la visione,
diciamo che il vedermi ogni mattina a scuola
No... Non so che cosa ho detto
Che per anni è riuscita a sopportare la visione della...
com'è che si dice in italiano?
Una persona che per quattro anni.  No...cinque
"Per cinque anni ha sopportato il mio analfabetismo"(Enrico)
Esatto e anche il modo in cui mi vestivo al liceo
Sto parlando di una mia amica storica... Vega
Salve a tutti
Scusami Vega, ci ho messo un po' a presentarti, ho dei problemi. No tranquillo non ti preoccupare
Ciao Gu eravamo a cena con degli amici in un pub
di fronte a me c'era una coppia di fidanzati
Lui dà un morso al suo bel panino e si sporca di maionese sul labbro
Lei lo guarda con nonchalance e gli pulisce la maionese con il dito
e sempre fissandolo negli occhi poi si lecca il dito
Eh la mia espressione era proprio di "Che c***o ho appena visto"
Vabbé dai è l'inizio di un p***o, tranquilla!
Io li avrei coperti poi del mio vomito, ed è l'inizio di un horror fidati
Che schifo!
La maionese è uno di quei cibi che è buonissimo...finché non viene preso. Se non lo mangi dalle bocche degli altri
Esatto. Si, diciamo in altre parole si
Ero in un vicolo molto stretto , con mia madre stavamo passando
e c'era una signora sulla cinquantina. Nel
momento in cui le siamo passati a fianco
si è calata i leggins fino a sopra le
ginocchia e da in piedi ha iniziato a p******e
Era un idrante, io una cosa del genere
non l'ho mai vista in vita mia
In tutto ciò mia madre si è messa ad urlare, insultandola
e l'ho dovuta trascinare via per paura che la signora si girasse e ci p*******e addosso
E' vero. La mamma ha cercato comunque di gestire la situazione al meglio...di abbassare i toni
Ma si può fare la  pipì in piedi? Se hai i leggins alle caviglie te la fai sui leggins però sono scelte di vita
Alla fermata dell'autobus vidi una signora che si tirò giù le braghe
e cominciò a c****e davanti a tutti. Ma questi hanno un problema con le deiezioni però!
Cercò anche di
nascondersi dietro a un cespuglio solo che
dall'altro lato c'erano tutti che la
stavano guardando
Vabbé però è quando ti scappa. A te non è mai capitato? Cioè io pure...no.
Beh alla fermata dell'auobus di c****e davanti a tutti no non mi è mai capitato
Scusate ho una vita semplice
E' rosso...Apetta
Hahahah un disastro! (Enrico)
Devo fare una premessa, io ho un
gatto che adora annusare il c**o  alla gente...
Ottima premessa...annusa sempre il buco del c**o della gente
Mia mamma una sera era lì e intanto il gatto le annusava il c**o no?
Io me ne vado e quando torno vedo mia mamma in piedi
che sta tenendo fermo il gatto e le sta
annusando il c**o e le diceva nel frattempo
"Così impari! Così sai che dà fastidio!" e
intanto le annusava il buco del c**o
A cioè lei annusava il c**o del gatto?!
Adesso non so se il mio gatto avesse appena c****o o meno però niente, ho trovato mia madre
con la faccia nel c**o del gatto
E niente, buona giornata ciao Gu e ciao ospite
Ma..un film di David Lynch. Ma perché? Per punirlo poi come se il gatto se la prendesse. Capito?
E' quello che dico. Il gatto sarà stato lì tipo "Bah, finalmente ha capito cosa deve fare"
Praticamente ero in piazza Duomo, ad un tratto un  piccione è andato a
schiantarsi contro un palo. A un certo
punto un ragazzo ha raccolto il piccione da terra
si è messo dell'acqua in bocca
e si è messo il becco del piccione in bocca
spruzzandogli dell'acqua per farlo riprendere. Alché il piccione si è ripreso e se ne è andato, è volato via
Cioè...il ragazzo poi è morto...dopo dieci minuti che ero lì dicevo "Ma veramente? Oh mio Dio!
Beh però ha salvato un piccione. Lo so però dai!
Dai! Cioè io preferirei veramente annusare il c**o del gatto
I piccioli sono bruttissimi. No non è che sono brutti, è che c'hanno duemila malattie tra l'altro
quindi lui chissà ha salvato il piccione, ha dato la sua vita per il piccione
O magari è il motivo per cui si è
messo dell'acqua in bocca
Dici che lo conosceva il piccione? A no pensavo tipo "Il motivo è che lo conosceva, tipo che era il suo
"John!"
Ciao Gu, un pomeriggio a Roma di ritorno dall'università, arrivo nel piazzale della stazione
e vedo un signore che sputa
addosso ad un piccione, dalle scale della
metro arriva un altro signore che inizia
a sputare sul signore che sputava sul piccione
Che al mercato mio padre comprò...Ciao
Vorrei sottolineare che sputi
deiezioni corporee, piccioni, vanno
fortissimo
No invece tu lo sai che una volta io...ho beccato in autobus uno che a buffo mi ha sputato
Ah. A me in metro questo è successo si
Volevo raccontarvi quando in prima liceo la mia
professoressa di italiano mi mandò in aula
professori a recuperare un libro appunto
della professoressa dimenticato
Appena arrivata apro la porta e la scena che
mi ritrovo davanti è la mia
professoressa di biologia, seduta sul
tavolo, con il preside in mezzo alle sue gambe
Ovviamente la frase che mi è uscita è stata "Che c***o ho appena visto"
Quello del preside. Te lo dico io
Diciamo che io e Vega abbiamo
testimoniato un sacco di cose
durante gli anni del liceo, che secondo me sono al limite...il nostro liceo che è avvenuto a Caracas...
si...frequentato questa scuola dei sobborghi del Sud America
Due nostri amici stavano litigando
F ha tirato da un lato della classe all'altro, non mi ricordo cosa in faccia a P
che si girato e gli ha lanciando un cestino della monnezza pieno
solo che in mezzo c'era una nostra amica che era seduta al banco...in prima fila...
che l'ha preso in testa e quindi
si è trovata tipo il cestino ribaltato in testa...pieno
Me la ricordo com'era. Com'era la nostra
amica prima di morire?
No la nostra mica è in buona salute...è emigrata all'estero, però quindi forse...
Allora l'anno scorso sono stata in Brasile un mese e mezzo di estate a fare volontariato
Praticamente li vabbé in Brasile immagino che saprai che le rapine sono veramente all'ordine del giorno
e c'era questa ragazza che stava camminando per strada così e si imbatte in questo rapinatore
Questo...incontro è stato abbastanza violento, più che violento minaccioso così
ma lei non si è lasciata spaventare dalla cosa
gli ha dato soldi così e poi ha deciso anche di iniziare una conversazione con questo ragazzo
ed è finita praticamente quasi in un flirt tra i due
in cui lei era, non so perché, affascinatissima da questo tipo...
Dal rapinatore?
Lui pure, boh, pareva che ci stesse provando con lei
Morale della favola, dopo che lei
era stata rapinata in maniera anche abbastanza brusca
lui l'ha invitata a mangiare
e sono andati a mangiare nel posto più vicino che c'era lì che è un McDonald
Alla fine della cena praticamente lui ha detto
"Vabbé adesso con i soldi che ti ho rubato ti offro la cena", e le ha offerto sta cena al McDonald
Lei poi è tornata a casa tutta contenta e ha raccontato sta storia a tutti gli amici
e sta passando anche un bellissimo messaggio
che è: se volete invitare una ragazza a cena, rapinatela
Tra l'altro fate anche una bellissima figura
perché lei vi pagherà la cena
ma in realtà...gliela offrite voi...sembra che  la offrite voi...quindi
Guarda ne uscite proprio alla grande. Ma pensa se la storia andava bene
"Guarda amore di mamma, allora papà...mi ha rapinata...ci siamo conosciuti  un giorno
che papà mi ha messo un coltello alla gola ma poi è finito tutto benissimo"
"Al McDonald, mi ha offerto la cena con i miei soldi". Esatto
Ciao Guglielmo ciao ospite
praticamente io vabbé ho una casa al mare, eravamo sul bagnasciuga io e mia cugina
e c'era un bimbo col pannolone che stava giocando. Immagino abbia avuto più o meno due anni massimo
Allora faccio "A che carino questo bimbo. Ciao bimbo come sei carino ma come ti chiami?"
Questo bimbo ci guarda...mi guarda e fa "Vai a fa i b******i"
Ci rimasi dal suo commento a questa cosa e siamo rimaste in silenzio per qualche minuto senza dirci niente
senza commentare questo fatto per un bel po' di tempo. E niente questo era quello che volevo dirvi. Ciao
Magari era il bambino di Roger Rabbit, sai quello col sigaro...si quello col sigaro al posto del ciuccio
Era lui! O magari il suo nome è Vaffaebu. Capito? Tipo africano e poi Chini di cognome
E' tipo "ionico", che se lo ripeti poi veloce...quindi dei genitori che gli volevano molto molto bene comunque
Vabbé la famiglia Chini si sa non è tanto carina
Vedo una coppia di signori anziani che...erano particolarmente strani
oltre al fatto che sembravano un pò sporchini. Questi due da quello che ho capito erano marito e moglie
La moglie stava seduta davanti e il marito dietro. E la moglie che sembrava una signora abbastanza pazza
faceva ogni due secondi il gesto di grattarsi la testa, ma si grattava forte, forte, sempre più forte
fino a quando a un certo punto il marito gridando davanti a tutti diceva "Ti devi spremere un limone in testa"
Tutto ciò in siciliano ovvero
*dialetto siciliano*
Esce un limone tagliato a metà, lo spreme sulla testa...sulla testa della moglie
glie lo strofina tutto in testa e gli fa "scìca scìca!", ovvero "strofina strofina!", e la moglie che si strofinava
"Scìca scìca!"
Oddio pensa che c'aveva in testa la signora!
Che schif... che spreme il limone! Ma poi il signore pronto a tutto però. C'aveva pure il limone!
Non serve per i pidocchi il limone? (Enrico)
Boh. L' aceto forse. A me m'hanno messo la benzina quando c'avevo i pidocchi
Ciao Gu, lavoro in un negozio da sei anni. C'erano una mamma con un bambino
dove lui guardava delle cose a sinistra del negozio e la mamma completamente a destra
Sento un rumore assordante di una scorreggia fortissima provenire da destra
Mi giro verso la mamma, la mamma mi guarda con stupore e poi guarda il figlio e fa
"Michael non si fanno queste cose!", ma in realtà era stata palesemente lei
E io la guardavo come per dire "Signora ho capito che è stata lei",
e lei continuava a sgridare il figlio che poverino era lì inerme
Cioè lei ha...no madre infame...mandato bevuto il figlio
Figlio che ora ha traumi per la vita, tipo se sente spostare una sedia piange. "Noo non lo fate!
Lui però un cecchino, che è stato lì a continuare a fissarli. E poi lui l'ha pure imbruttita
Anche lui...comunque ragazzi campioni mondiali di dissimulare eh?
"Signora lei ha scorreggiato eh?"
Che dire ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
Io ringrazio Vega per essersi prestata...cosi...che piacere!
Ti vedo. Ora uscirai che...non aspetterò mai più un autobus a una fermata con lo stesso stato d'animo di prima
Ringrazio anche voi che avete guardato questo video
e soprattutto fatemi sapere se anche a voi magari è capitato un qualcosa di analogo
o se magari vi è successo un qualcosa di assurdo. O se avete una vita piatta e banale
Io naturalmente come sempre vi invito a farmi sapere quali sarebbero dei temi che vi piacerebbero
e allo stesso tempo vi invito a iscrivervi a questo canale, attivare le notifiche se non volete perdere nessun video
e ci vediamo la prossima settimana con un altro "Vita Buttata"
Ciao...Ciao
"Bravissimi ora vi inceneriamo!", "Ora vi bruciamo la retina"